قله المساعدات الانسانيه وغلاء الاسعار
الناتجه عن الحرب في اوكرانيا من اهم
العوامل التي ساهمت في تعقيد الوضع الامني
الغذائي في سمل وضع اثر صلبا في حياه
اطفال النازحين
عن هذه المخيمات بسبب نقص تمويل وغبت معها
فرحتها هؤلاء الصغار
ان اطفال المخيم يعيشون في حاله صعبه منذ
ان اختفت مراكز التغذيه الاطفال
نتمنى ان يتم فتح مراكز تساعدهم على
البقاء على قيد الحياه لاننا لا نملك شيئا
ويقول خالد احمد مدير صندوق الاغاثه
الافريقي الذي اشرف على مركز تغذيه في هذا
المخيم ان جميع التغذيه في هذه المخيمات
اغلقا منذ سنوات نتيجه ندره المساعدات
الانسانيه وغلاء المواد الاساسيه عبر
كارليفه
نحن كصندوق الاغاثه الافريقي فتحنا مركزا
لتغذيه الاطفال وكبار السن لكن توقف بسبب
نقص التمويل كان يعطي وجبتين ساخنتين
يوميا مكونتين من مواد مغذيه كان يستفيد
منهما 400 الى 500 شخص لكن للاسف هذا غيره
متوفر من الان ونحن في حاله جفاف عارم
وخلاص
ويعالج منذ سنوات من اسوء جفاف يضرب
البلاد منذ اربعين عاما يرى ان ندره هطول
الامطار في اربعه مواسم متتاليه ما يهدد
حياه اكثر من سبعه ملايين صوماليا بحسب
التقارير انسانيه عبد الرحمن بخاري
العربيه مقديشو